foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the lights change how everything looks  it's hard to find our house harsh is the  dark house with no lights  in this family it's the scientists  versus the artists  [Music]  Sammy's on my team takes after me  what kind of movie You're Gonna Make  You dismissed what he does it's playful  or imaginative  afford to be a little encouraging  she should have been the concert piano  player but she got in her heart is what  you got you can't just  it's more important than your hobby can  you stop calling it a hobby  [Music]  you always have to be the center of  attention stop shouting at her that has  been nothing but disrespect from you I'm  Your Mother  family hot  it'll tear you into  you stop making movies that'll break  your mother's heart I don't know what to  do anymore you do what your heart says  you have to  what was your favorite part  [Music]  thank you